on est arrivé à un stade où
nous nous sommes non seulement plus
considéré par notre hiérarchie
administrative mais même plus écoutés
c'est à dire que les directives tombent
parfois par un simple mail parfois par
un courrier de temps à autre à
l'occasion d'une réunion collective et
on n'a pas forcément été prévenus et
lorsqu'on tente d'opposer une résistance
à ce que l'on considère comme étant un
projet néfaste pour les patients et bien
l'administration sec comment s'y prendre
parce que elle s'entoure très souvent de
collègues malheureusement et là je
voudrais mettre le doigt aussi sur une
faille du système qu'on a créé deux
collègues qui
hélas prennent le parti de
l'administration pour vous acculé et
vous forcer à l'obéissance
notre système est totalement déshumanisé
il est caporalisée il est soviétisée et
je dirais même que
la fuite de personnel qu'on a
aujourd'hui la démission des médecins
est liée davantage encore à ce problème
qualitatif de perte de sens qu'au
problème quantitatif de perte des moyens
nous avons l'habitude de travailler avec
peu de moyens mais en revanche nous ne
pouvons plus supporter d'être traités de
cette manière
[Musique]